[Musique]
oui mr d'apparaître comme si ses 1100
morts depuis sept ans j'ai choisi un
sujet extrêmement chargé le projet de
loi 96 le fait que la charte de la
langue française a besoin d'être
actualisées et que présentement il ya un
énorme enjeu du point de vue des
communautés autochtones ou
l'actualisation la charte de la langue
française n'a pas
d'article qui protègent ou qui reconnaît
justement l'importance aussi de
comprendre la réalité l'entité
autochtone
j'appelle sauter un peu la poupée russe
de la langue anglaise avant que
française les langues autochtones au
travail parce que présentement un des
enjeux je dirais c'est que dans la
mobilisation pour la protection de la
langue française
il existe de gros auprès des groupes
comprennent totalement les enjeux que
les communautés autochtones essaie de
mettre de l'avant sur la protection leur
langue sur la route que cela vienne des
langues qui sont reconnus comme des
langues officielles sur leur territoire
donc des territoires millénaire des
langues qui parle depuis des milliers
d'années ici mais qui ont encore un
enjeu d'être reconnus financer protéger
avec des lois comme c'est le cas pour le
français et l'anglais les deux langues
officielles au canada
mais l'autre est un autre groupe oc qui
existe et celui là on voit beaucoup dans
les médias sociaux on le voit dans les
commentaires on voit aussi des attaques
avant les personnes des communautés
autochtones qui veulent justement levée
des drapeaux rouges pour de l'attention
avec votre projet de loi par ceux qui
disent que nous attaquons la langue
française que nous nous battons contre
eux donc il nous met en position d'
ennemi alors que nous notre position
c'est de dire mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'est pas juste un simple dans des
alliances liées à la protection de nos
langues je pense qu'il y aurait dit
qu'ils auraient été plus naturel que les
personnes qui veulent protéger la langue
l'identité québécoise francophone et
même franco-canadienne n'oubliez pas
qu'il ya beaucoup de francophones dans
brésilien da
mais c'est ces alliances ne se font pas
naturellement parce que
il ya souvent une approche très fermé
par rapport à la langue et on se rend de
plus en plus compte que c'est un lien
aussi avec le fait que nous ne sommes
pas inclus dans cette conversation nous
sommes plutôt coincée dans une chicane
de clocher et nous essayons de lui faire
rentrer une perspective qui n'est pas le
bienvenu puisque c'est une jeune candide
un conflit qui existe depuis en quelques
centaines d'années lié au fait que la
colonisation anglaise a supplanté la
colonisation française
à l'époque il ya eu des ententes qui se
sont fait où justement pour faciliter le
passage à la colonie anglaise on a
reconnu puis on a aussi promis de
protéger non seulement la religion mais
la langue des personnes qui étaient en
nouvelle france ce qui a facilité
justement la colonisation mais aussi ce
qui a évité qui est des rebellions après
justement la colonisation puisque les
questions d'identité étaient reconnus
mais les communautés autochtones n'ont
pas été dans ces ententes la vie de la
même manière nous on avait encore les
traiter de multiples et pour lesquels
nation on était
quelles étaient nos alliances parle pas
au site on faisait partie d'une autre
façon de réfléchir donc on n'était pas
vraiment des citoyens la nouvelle france
des citoyens du canada anglais on était
des autochtones et vous le savez par le
passé il y avait un besoin d'être en
alliance avec les communautés
autochtones mais une fois que la
colonisation était bien enclenché que
les populations étaient vraiment
beaucoup plus nombreuse pouvait se
défendre aussi et bien on a commencé un
processus de colonisation encore plus
grand les communautés autochtones donc
par les réserves par les pensionnats la
destruction d'armes d'ailleurs vous
comprenez pourquoi je porte ce gilet
aujourd'hui
et c'est là où est ce que je me rends
compte que dans ce concept de protection
de la langue anglaise et française qui
sont de langue qui supplantent les
langues autochtones présentement en
ôtant aloi que ans en personne qui l ont
parlé en colonisation des personnes qui
sont maintenant autochtone et qui ont
soit comme première ou deuxième langue
le français ou l'anglais
la pensée derrière celle là c'est la
pensée du theron nullius à dire que
quand les français les anglais les
espagnols partout sur le continent sont
arrivés c'était de dire qu'il n'y avait
personne qui habitait auparavant et donc
que tout était bon a colonisé donc nous
nos langues sont quasiment considérée
comme inexistante ou
sont comme les arbres et les fleurs et
font juste partie de la nature et on
peut donc en disposer et c'est ce qu'on
peut comprendre dans ses programmations
puisqu'on y est pas inclus ou qu'on doit
se débattre énormément pour faire
entendre nos voix nous nous nos
arguments et aussi personne n'a envie de
dépenser de l'argent on dirait bien ni
au fédéral et au provincial pour
protéger les langues autochtones
donc ça crée une désolidarisation des
communautés autochtones envers les
arguments des personnes qui veulent
protéger de français ça aurait dû être
le contraire et je me souviens très bien
moi quand j'étais très jeune moi le
respect de l'hymne aux moines que tu
fait que je ne parlais pas c'était très
problématique pour moi il n'y avait pas
une très grande
très grande encouragements sur a parlé
il nous met par exemple on réussit
énormément de mon français que je parle
bien français
cependant du côté de mon père il y avait
un encouragement garder l'aspect
culturel à voir l'importance de
l'identité de la culture la langue donc
en solidarité moi je me suis tourné puis
je devais moi aussi je veux protéger la
langue française veulent encourager je
veux comprendre et respecter le fait
francophone surtout francophone et
autochtone d'ailleurs un bon moment
beaucoup d aspects de démo quotidien
tourné vers le français cependant tous
ces aspects où on nous ignore où on
tourne le dos à notre le quai pour
protéger nos langues mais qui vient
c'est comment je voudrais de tournée
vient justement des communautés
francophones et bien vous comprendrez
que sade et celle des risques est de
plus en plus de jeunes autochtones vont
se tourner vers l'anglais parce qu'ils
veulent je faire un choix entre les
anglais les français
c'est vraiment pas seule option c'est de
dire quelles langues parlent les autres
communautés autochtones à travers l'île
à grand torture et la majorité dans
l'anglais comme langue première ou
seconde donc il n'ya pas un intérêt
à voir le français comme une langue de
solidarité mais avoir juste un choix
avec quel angle je peux parler à mon
voisin qui est de l'île nations voisines
donc d'ouvrir cette charte sans prendre
en perspective justement des membres qui
les les requêtes très simple des
communautés ça ouvre justement 17
d'accusation et ça ouvre à un
affaiblissement la protection des
langues parce qu'une langue tu peux pas
forcer les gens à la part les multiples
par exemple inspiré des gens vouloir la
parler la protéger à vouloir s'exprimer
dans cette langue
donc ce sont des enjeux qui sont en 2020
d'où je pense qu'ils auraient dû être
déjà
explorée déjà échangé mais qui sont
encore moi je l'arbre et les corses
entre lesquels les communautés telles
que l'on doive se débattent pour se
faire entendre
vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi c'est
extrêmement chargé pourquoi c'est
extrêmement difficile d'en discuter mais
souvent ces discussions là je l'attend
sur l'idée de je sais que c'est
compliqué je sais que ça rajoute une
couche déjà une longue et difficile pour
le langue la langue française mais
oubliez pas aussi qu'en 90 quand la
séparation du québec était une
discussion très actif d'ailleurs qu'ils
étaient élaborées justement au point
d'avoir un référendum un des aspect
légal qui avait été opposé au référendum
c'est que
l'idée du référendum avait été faite
sans avoir en tête les enjeux
autochtones donc développe protéger une
langue semble avoir en tête les enjeux
des autres nations avec lesquelles vous
partager le territoire ça peut devenir
quelque chose qui vient bien comment je
peux te dire affaiblir les fondations de
ce que vous voulez protéger alors
comprenez que ce sont des enjeux sont
chargées qui sont des fois gracia
racialisées au point où est ce que
beaucoup de personnes par exemple de la
nation maroc qui ont l'anglais comme
langue première ou seconde peuvent se
voir à faire agresser parce que si tu
trouves ça en français puis maintenant
et cette somme aux canines goergl vous
comprenez comment ça devient des fois
chargé et c'est pas là c'est pourquoi je
ne sais pas l'opinion c'est pas la
manière de faire de tout le québec le to
canada mais c'est devient sec et où
devant et celle qui confronte justement
les communautés autochtones donc il faut
appeler à une cellule il faut appeler à
une reconnaissance des langues
autochtones à une ouverture justement de
la protection des langues autochtones
sur tout particulièrement après les
enjeux de la réconciliation
alors s'il vous plaît n'hésitez pas à
partager ce n'est pas non plus entrer en
réflexion je sais que ça devient
extrêmement
agressif quand on en parle mais si j'en
parle aujourd'hui c'est justement en
l'honneur de mon parti lui a fait tout
son possible pour pouvoir protéger la
scène est ma langue mon identité et donc
en échange je veux faire la même chose
pour lui cependant qu est-ce qui dit que
nos enfants eux auront cette même
approche le si on ne garde pas cette
ouverture là après toutes ces années
alors je suis de mes semaines il s'était
pas en parler n'était pas échangé mais
pensez vraiment au fait de ce qui peut
se dit fier une langue et ce qui peut
l'amener à disparaître